foreign
[Music]
you're an Avenger
you have a daughter but you've lost a
lot of time like me
I'm the man who can give you more time
Scott you cannot trust him
I just lost so much he can give us a
second chance
he will bring me what I need for
everything you call a life
will end
you may not want her to watch this we
had a deal
you thought you could win I
report yourself
quantumania ready PG-13 in theaters
February 17th you're an interesting man
Scotland you have a daughter
dad you're an Avenger
have I killed you before
on February 17th he can shatter
existence nothing can prepare you you
may not want her to watch this for the
new Dynasty
[Music]
Ant-Man and the WASP Quantum media ready
PG-13 experience it in 3D February 17th
[Music]